thank you
[Music]
meet the Japanese man who gets paid to
do nothing
yeah his name is
how much does he get paid oh that's like
the Japanese Prince
he just stands there for ceremonial
activities no definitely not that he's a
38 year old Tokyo resident he charges 71
in Americans with 10 000 Yen wow per
booking to accompany clients and just
hang out with them as a companion dude I
could do that wow so he talks us does he
say anything he talks and stuff he's a
good he's a good hang that's how he's
doing something
well some are arguing that he's not
really doing anything at all yeah he's
not providing like a service like a late
skilled labor but Joe didn't you say in
Japan some people are like really lonely
yeah so this is a good service
because so there's like a um there's a
Consulting service because there's like
this phenomenon that's going on where
like people just [ __ ] become Hermits
and they don't go out they don't do [ __ ]
their parents can't get them to leave
the house and so now there's this like
big sister service where like big sister
huh they'll come suck their dick whoa
well they they'll it's like they ease
them into society
but they have the role of like being a
big sister like hey did you eat anything
today like you want to hang out
reminding them of stuff and then they'll
just yeah and then they'll come in and
it's like non-threatening like big
brothers can be threatening but like
older sisters like it's more nurturing
more nurturing and it's like hey uh why
don't we try going to the park today or
whatever right and then like they'll
start to integrate into society again so
it's like they have a pretty good
success rate but their services like
that trying to help these people that
are like yeah it's like taskrabbit
things for like social yeah yeah wow I
don't know if this is what this is how
did that happen how did that like
phenomenon what do you think caused that
[ __ ] Japanese people are home bodies you
know I watch something but I forgot it
so I don't want to make up the reasons
so you have unlimited amounts of really
[ __ ] quality video games and porn
it's got to be video games so you're
jacking off all day and you're playing
games all day like the wow kids and
you're just like why the [ __ ] would you
go out that's true wow kids become wow
adults right not exactly wowing women
and then they have like wild kids and
they're even worse because they're
probably just stuck inside yeah yeah wow
uh so he's yeah he's he's made like 300
G's in the last year right 300 G's or in
the past four years but he's he's booked
4 000 sessions so far you could do like
rent a family you could do like there's
a lot of funny rent a friend Services
out there that are kind of trolley so
it's not serious but then they play
along with it because they do like a lot
of role playing that's fun though yeah
so it's like the you know how like
it's like half jokey doing it okay so it
could be one of those things too yeah
yeah that's interesting well um
apparently a quarter of his so he has he
has a quarter million followers on
Twitter where that's where he finds most
of his clients right and roughly a
quarter of them are repeat customers
including one his his most
um
um booked customer hired him 270 times
holy [ __ ] dude imagine they've become
best friends on the job so when he's off
the clock he's like nah [ __ ] get away
from me like because he's like it's only
a professional thing like you're we're
not really friends he doesn't want to
[ __ ] with his income yeah you want to be
nice give me some money it might be nice
right now yeah
what if that's what it's like he just
turns it on for like I wonder if it's
friendship yeah yeah or if it's do they
did they specify the service or is he
obligated to companionship it's just
hanging yeah
oh um his job has taken him to places
such as a park with the person who
wanted to play on a seesaw
so that's a little weird that's weird uh
they should just [ __ ] you know that'd be
less weird he also um this one this one
got me this one actually got me last
night when I was reading about this
he uh
he was hired to stand outside of a train
window and wave at a complete stranger
as they get taken oh that's sad that
means that person just wanted to feel
like cared for like that he'll be missed
he should be missing man that's crazy
that's such a simulated so empty yeah
not crazy yeah imagine he just like
[ __ ]
you want it
no sorry
can I hire you
don't keep me up
so I know like a lot of the kids these
days they have their own iPads and stuff
right so that's like one thing that
keeps them inside and then if you live
in like a big city then you're not
really going out to play like in the
suburbs right so I feel like that that
combination is a huge one where they
barely go outside
so
um if you have kids that are raised like
that then when they have kids
their kids are even like more hermit I
guess because like this type of
phenomenon like I see not just in Japan
but I see it here too so it's kind of
happening all over the world what if it
corrects itself like several Generations
later because when they realize like
wait what there's an outside world and
then it's like the Matrix all over again
and they break so stupid I remember
something now
um it has this like Failure to Launch
like fear of
adulting kind of thing so like
it's like it's pretty easy for them to
kind of stay home and then like going
out and doing the responsible [ __ ] job
relationships all those things are like
too [ __ ] scary so they stay home yeah
but I I don't blame them though because
like once you learn about how the world
is working it's like [ __ ] do it do I
really want to work for the rest of my
life when I can just be a streamer
that's also why one of the reasons of
the low birth rate because they're like
why the [ __ ] would I wanna talk about
kids and do more [ __ ] yeah so they
actually have a point but it's like it's
the birth rate also so the [ __ ] rate is
low too extremely low oh so yeah even
just like you confirmed it's low not
necessarily so like apparently it's a
small percentage of dudes having a lot
of [ __ ] sex but then
um generally the overall I guess
percentage is like relationships are low
too so like just like monogamous
standard traditional like that kind of
stuff is not really existent and people
are hooking up and isn't there a problem
you said with like people don't want to
move to Japan from the outside to live
there like it's hard to so it's a very
homogeneous like pretty racist
old-school Society there's a chick
there's a chick who uh hired him because
she had a Dr an Indian dress called
asari that she wanted to wear but she
didn't want to embarrass her friends and
so she hired him to just hang out with
her while she wore the sorry so she
could wear it out in public wow that's
very complex but it's pretty cool I
guess yeah yeah I guess do you think it
comes from I like how engaged he is
with what's going on he's like I don't
care dude he's milking this yeah he's
he's pretty tight do you think it's
because it's a very suppressive like
culture like you're not supposed to do
this well I know I know they don't have
any shame in um having compartmentalized
services
that's one and then like another thing
is
um they're not as open as we are with
friends and family as far as like having
these conversations everything is a
script or like everything is like what
do you call them pre-rehearsal no it's
like um
like the mores or no no it's called when
you have like
the way you conduct yourself with each
interaction so like we have these when
we walk up to a cashier right and then
we bring like products right they go how
was your day today there's like there's
like those it's
etiquette right so so traditionally
there's that depending on who you
address okay and then so you're never
like comfortable in the sense of what's
allowed here so out here it's more like
there's there's true freedom and how you
have friendships how you speak you speak
from your heart all that stuff what I
know of it is like the younger
generation is getting a little bit
better but
traditionally they never say what they
feel because it's shunned and it's just
a different world where like people
don't even know themselves because they
were never allowed to be themselves so
it'd be weird if you like went up to a
cashier and you're like
hey what the [ __ ] really going on man
yeah yeah you could you get real with me
you're like
[Laughter]
no no my Insider perspective and this is
just like my
view of the culture just from like
growing up in it and everything right is
like
the way I see it is you have a lot of
geniuses creating systems of culture
like like of the infrastructure the
building way things should be and then
you have a really disciplined idiot
group that will just follow without
thinking so then it they appear smart
because everything is orderly right but
what it really is is they're just
obedient yeah so then everything's on
time everything works but they can't
really think outside of those parameters
so when you go out there and you try to
like customize your meal you try to do
all this [ __ ] like they'll just
malfunction and be like I don't know how
to do that they only know how to follow
a system that some genius created yeah
so then when you have a society like
that you're taught how to conduct
yourself in these interactions with
other human beings this is how you
address friendships this is how you
address whatever so then when it diverts
from that and you're like oh [ __ ] um I
don't know if my friends would accept
this so I'll do it this way so it kind
of makes sense in that structure because
they're not used to just being like hey
you want to [ __ ] do this real quick
it is generally speaking right there are
people that divert out of that but like
yeah do you think that the birth rate
problem is a is a backfired effect of
the rigidness of society hell yeah dude
it it it's like everyone gets the [ __ ]
in at the bargain so like if you come
from an older generation who just
follows right the new generation is
smarter so they're they're they're
they're they're more Global they're like
[ __ ] connected to the internet and
it's kind of the same way here right
where we're like saying man [ __ ] that
I'm to work for like a company and give
my like I want a better work-life
balance or whatever for them it's like
it's worse in Japan because you have
people overworking and dying right yeah
there's that phenomenon happening there
they see like once especially for women
so like once they become married they're
still expected to do the traditional
gender role stuff of like running the
household and whatever but it's a modern
capitalist Society where both people
work so so they're the women are still
expected to raise the children clean the
house do all that the guys don't have to
do it so the women are like so they're
double duty yeah I'm gonna still work
while I have to do this [ __ ] and then
the guys are like well once I become a
father so the life goal of being that is
so unattractive because the expected
roles of Parenthood is like now you
become a father and all of your life is
dedicated to your children you don't
have a personal life anymore and then
the guys are like I'd rather be a kid
and [ __ ] play video games so what's
the point of integrating into society is
just more work that makes sense and then
there's no hope for um advancement in
lives yeah well that's [ __ ] lame it
is it's like slavery right so like but
before people were ignorant so you had
an obedient group of people that'll just
fall in line but now they're like seeing
like people making it on YouTube and all
these other things so they're just like
but it's not as free and entrepreneurial
is out here so I think that's still
frowned upon probably why they're like
[ __ ] that I'm gonna opt out of this
Society dude they just need to not give
a [ __ ] I think it's slowly getting there
though the younger generation is gonna
be like I don't care anymore they're
just gonna be more casual and it's gonna
end up probably like here you know like
where people I think that I don't care
is them just staying home all day and
not working and doing [ __ ] it's like
anti-society but it'll spread you know
as like
yeah like
yeah no no no no Bobby 100 says it's
over for us but how does this all relate
to Anthony
[Music]
[Music]